[Music]
let's move on to seattle washington
justin joins us there justin what is
going on
hey guys how's it going great how can we
help
so my girlfriend's parents convinced my
girlfriend that credit score matters and
they got her a credit card now she plans
on using that credit card to buy a car
oh boy how do i convince her that that
is a very bad idea and that she needs to
have
a surgery with her credit card and get
rid of it
well a simple answer justin sell the
girlfriend ah
there it is
hey
george campbell ladies and gentlemen
i'll be here all week yeah
uh not a bad idea i'll add to that
really quickly because george will give
you some really tactical advice i think
you uh
i think you fake the snowflake syndrome
justin are you aware of what this is
i am not this is a passive aggressive
you ghost her for a little bit give her
the silent treatment and you make her
she she's like why why is justin not you
know what i mean like total silence this
is what women do very well to men the
silence
shoulder the cold shoulder and the guys
trying to figure out what's going on i
think you reverse it and you just really
and and the snowflake syndrome part of
it is you act like you're very offended
or that you're shook
you're shook by her the suggestion that
she
would buy a car on a credit card and
just
let it let her see how it just really
freaks you out man justin i know we've
been unhelpful so far
this conversation it might it'll set you
up for george's tech justin you you like
this girl right how long you been
together
now we've been together for coming up on
five years now five years whoa is there
a future here i'm wondering what have
the money conversations been like
clearly you've talked about your values
around money right
yeah so i definitely want to
like stay debt free have no credit cards
my parents have been following you guys
for years and they're getting out of
debt uh using
your guys's method and i just want to
take the next step and i want to become
a millionaire but
credit cards are not the way to go well
i think you have an honest conversation
that isn't attacking her it's not hey
you got to cut up the card today it's
hey listen my plan is to become a
millionaire i'd love for you to be a
part of that plan as we move towards
marriage and i know that a credit card
is not going to be helpful in getting
there and here's why and i can give you
a third party tool we did an episode all
about this on my podcast the fine print
and it is episode 7 the dirty truth
behind your credit score we also have
one in episode two the true cost of
credit card rewards so here's what i'll
do listen to that together yes sit down
listen to it and it'll spark some
conversation
because i think the reason she wants to
get the credit card can uh you we could
argue again say well listen we just
proved to you that that's not that's not
the case you don't need your credit
score to do any of this stuff and
there's easy ways around it you can live
your life without the score you can live
your life without the card and you can
live your life without debt
so justin i'm going to encourage you to
do both of those things and get on the
same page and truthfully if you can't
align on those values i don't see this
being a long-term relationship beyond
this it's already a long term at five
five years man justin we gotta get this
figured out pretty quick man
i what i
i didn't want to propose until we got
this straightened out absolutely right i
know that the number one cause of
divorce is money problems this guy gets
it justin listen we're rooting for you
man i want her to get on the same page i
don't want it to become her parents
versus your opinion that's a dangerous
game to play so get her on board if not
we might have to to sell the girlfriends
i